welcome back to the simons institute
it's a shame we can't be at calvin lab
but
you know this is this is what we can do
hopefully i hope it'll be
effective um this way a big thank you to
to
uh alley uh for for organizing the
reunion um uh and
and you know typically i say a few words
about the the reunion it's intended to
after a year intended to get people back
to be looking back on what you've done
um what came out of the program and also
looking forward at
where the field should go um and and you
know a year seems to be the right time
scale
um we don't stream the talks we don't
put these up on youtube and that's
intentional because you know it is you
are supposed to be
feeling free to speculate on new
directions for the field
without having uh you know the broader
audience watching um
one other thing i wanted to to say you
know in the next month or so you're
going to see
requests to update the research report
that you provided at the end of the
program
um you know describing outcomes and
collaborators and publications and so on
um and the program organizers will be
putting together a final report based on
this so thanks very much for all your
efforts are doing that it's very
important for the institute in reporting
to the science foundation very important
for
um for for us in applying for
fundraising to keep the institute going
uh and and you know what we really want
to see is um big outcomes of the of the
program new results new directions
impact on your career things like that
so so please do spend some time
helping us out with that we appreciate
it um
and i guess in that vein we're always
looking for new programs so if you want
to organize something have an idea for
something
that you'd like to see happen please do
let us know
um all right a big thank you also to to
uh
uh jessie gill uh who did all the
organizational simon's institute side
there he is um uh
and uh omid faras is there in the
background as well
um okay so um uh
ali you wanna say a few words about
about yeah i wanted to add to what peter
said so i
i i think in july i kind of put together
the the interim report for this semester
and there were like a bunch of exciting
uh publications that are you know in
submission or like manuscripts
uh what's since then has happened is i
think you know
a lot of those have become you know
mature and online and published at
excellent venues
and more generally i think looking back
over the past 12 months since the
since since the end of the the program i
think there's been some
pretty notable results you know some of
them you know are represented in
in this program so i just wanted to kind
of add it to what peter said
there are all kinds of beautiful and
strong publications please don't forget
to add them to the
um whatever
sort of form formula
is being sent to gather this information
it's a very valuable for the institute
so
i think in advance for that for you know
so carefully like
noting these things i also wanted to add
i saw that some of the past reunion
workshops
did record the talks and put them on
youtube and so i've kindly asked
jesse to tell this to rit people so i
think each of you have received
um a uh
disclosure form so you have you can each
of you have like uh
your own choice of whether you're fine
with that or not but you know i
i thought it would be a good thing for
the community uh uh to
uh to do that and so i i yeah
basically i've seen my impression from
acr conferences held online over the few
last few months crypto
then tcc then asia crypt i felt like
there was lively discussion despite
everything being served on
youtube and uh so i think that
that would strike like a reasonable
balance for um
yeah so just just do that i hope i'm
assuming peter is fine because i saw
pastoring workshops doing it
so i kind of been yeah just
told justin to do so but i hope it's
fine um
either way again if you feel
uncomfortable it's completely fine
nobody's gonna
pressure you just like you know don't
sign the consent form
and with that you know we do have a a
pretty exciting program today
uh we have in between i think reasonably
generous breaks
uh for fueling up and otherwise
um i think we can use the
gather dot down in between also not just
during the bigger
sort of so-called lunch break um and
so yeah i'll try to stick around and
gather a town in general and then feel
free to join
as well um and without any questions
about the format or
um yeah i think we should just generally
you know
ask questions i think it's a good thing
and uh
it's pretty intimate right now to become
less intimate but
hard to imagine more intimate in this
and with that maybe we should just get
started and i think ron has the first
slot and
the virtual stages is yours and thank
you everybody for preparing talks
can you hear me can you see the screen
yeah okay hi everyone great to see uh
everyone even though it's just virtual
um so my talk is going to be about local
proofs approaching the witness length
this is a joint work with uh nogoronzvi
and before i start the kind of technical
talk you know because this is a reunion
i thought maybe
to start off by reminiscing about the
good old days
where we do all kinds of neat things
like fly on airplanes
and go to a restaurant or you know visit
the simons institute and go to the
golden gate bridge on a beautiful clear
day
and even do a little bit of a research
so uh apologies to the spooner who's
cut in half it's the best picture that i
had of actual
work being done and people in the photo
um sorry
what is a restaurant um i don't remember
such a thing
i'll tell you about it someday um
yes i just want to take the opportunity
to thank the organizers of the workshop
and this reunion uh
for organizing a great program that i
really enjoyed
okay so on to that kind of more
technical talk
and uh you know the thing you should
have in mind in this talk is
pcps which i think we all probably uh
have
know and hopefully love and i know that
i think
maybe almost everyone here is an expert
but because it's being recorded i'm
gonna go
no not too slowly but i will go over
definitions
quickly so what is a pcp what's a way to
take you know
an incredibly complex proof of the one
that we have on this on this
blackboard and encode it write it down
in a different format
that you can verify by only reading very
few bits
and you know probably i'll know the
definition but let's go through it
quickly so
we're trying to check whether uh you
know statement x is true belongs to
language l
our verifier is given x it's given
oracle access to
prove string pi which it can query in a
few locations
and what it requires that if x is in the
language there exists a proof that will
convince
our verifier if x is not the language
that no matter what proof you write down
our verifier is going to reject with uh
or you know accept the probability
almost half
so the problem the verifier is
probabilistic of course
and the key parameters that we are going
to focus on in this talk are the number
of queries number of bits that the
verifier reads
and the proof length there are other
things that you people do care about
but that's the focus uh our focus for
today
okay so we have this notion of pcps and
it turns out that we also can actually
build them
and particularly we have this you know
amazing pcp theorem
proven in the early 90s which tells us
that you can take any classical
standard proof any any np proof and
encode it into a pcp
that can be verified by only reading the
constant number of bits and with only
polynomial overhead
it's really amazing result and it's good
to kind of reflect back on how amazing
it is because it's been really
transformative on a number of fields so
starting from complexity you know it's
kind of uh
rewritten the entire field of hardness
of approximation and it's
had amazing impacts on circuit lower
bound so results by ryan and others
um more recently and last uh
fox and stock we've heard of a matrix
rigidity lower bounds from
from pcp's carpolitum collapse theorems
and you know the list goes on so
a lot of influence on complexity theory
and also of course a huge influence on
cryptography
where it was used you know starting with
works by killian and mikali
to construct succinct argument systems
um
we've seen a lot of work on that
especially in recent years
to range into you know results on zero
knowledge proofs
in particular you know non-black box
techniques of barack rely on
pcps so really a huge influence
and something that i think is also
incredibly remarkable is that this
really very theoretical work has in
recent years also become very practical
so there are uh you know startup
companies um
a lot of there's a lot of money going
into actually
building and deploying pcps and their
variants
okay so it's becoming something that's
actually being used which is i think is
really remarkable
okay so the focus of our talk today is
about making our pcps shorter you know
how short can our pcps be this
continuation of a long line of work
and the key question here which remains
open and we're going to rephrase it in a
second but
you know if you take uh whatever problem
that you like that you can verify
um non-deterministically in time t can
you construct a pcp a constant query pcp
for that problem
where the length of the pct say is just
linear in t
can you do kind of get pcps with just a
constant overhead
and that question is open but it's also
kind of it's a little bit annoying
because it
really heavily depends on the
computational model
so if you define you know n is usually
defined with respect to turing machines
and if you switch to asking about you
know a multi-tape journey machine or
something
then there are some logarithmic
overheads involved and the question you
know
won't resolve for that computational
model so the the
really the question that the community
has settled on is looking
at the computational model of boolean
circuits and the way that you can find
the questions
there is whether circuit sat csat has a
piece
constant query pcp where the proof
length is linear in the size of the
circuit
and so so that that is entirely open
and you know if you really don't like
boolean circuits just know that this
would also give you
kind of pcps with a single logarithmic
factor for tuning machines
so i think it's a really natural
question but if you don't
like it just because it's natural here's
some like more concrete motivation
by the way stop me with questions at any
time as long as you have a question or
yeah so so now you said it depends on
the model
and then you set up for this uh specific
question does it depend on what
unlike the circuit and and what uh
gateshead
where the fan in and um
i mean so basically yes it depends on
the
the concrete computational model if your
computational model can be
you know uh emulated by boolean circuits
with constant overhead then that would
also solve it for your model
yeah so so when you say a better
question
you mean circuits which circuit
right so um for seaside
i think the typical result stability
stated for
constant famine circuits you're welcome
to correct me if i'm wrong
um and then you know the basis of gates
if it's just constant fanning you can
emulate with constant overhead
yeah or just count edges if you want
unbounded
right yeah even better yeah existing
uh at least the results on linear size
pcps with subliminal query complexity
are for
uh you know finding two and it's
explicitly used in the construction that
the the the fanning is a is uh some
known constant uh
are you just ignorant actually related
to uh the second two results that i'm
going to mention so
if i remember i'll bring it up there um
so if you like the question great if you
don't like it and want more motivation
well
first motivation that i want to mention
is to towards construction of succinct
argument systems
and actually it turns out that their the
length of the proof
is not the most important thing in the
world what actually
really matters is the complexity of
generating the proof
but you know the length of the proof is
a lower bound on the complexity of
generating the proof so
if you want efficient proof you better
have short pcps
okay so it's kind of a bottleneck
towards getting efficient provers which
is really important in success arguments
and second uh so having very short pcps
is going to be useful to get hurdles of
approximation results in fine-grained
complexity
so beyond what we what we currently know
there's some really interesting open
questions there
okay so what is the state of the art we
want constant overhead turns out that we
were very close to that and we have been
for the past 15 years
so for circuits that we know pcps with
constant query complexity
and you know quasi-linear proof length
so the name of the game is really
reducing this polylog down to a constant
and turns out we even know how to do
that to work by uh benson stone kaplan
co-party in the ear actually gets linear
overhead in the proof length
but unfortunately the the queer
complexity is very far from what we
would like it to be
so it's something like enter the epsilon
and epsilon has a heavy dependence
uh there's a heavy dependence on epsilon
in the proof line
okay so that's the state of the art and
today we're not going to
you know improve the state of the art
for pcps but rather we're going to look
at a relaxation of the notion of pcps
which again i think many of you are
familiar with
so it's something called an interactive
oracle proof introduced into independent
works about one by
uh bensasson kia's and spooner and the
other in a joint work together with uh
omari golden guy rothbon
so it's an interactive oracle proof it's
basically kind of a hybrid between an
interactive proof a public one
interactive proof
and a pcp so the way that the game works
is as follows we have a verifier and
approver like
an interactive proof and now the
verifier sends over a long string like a
pcp
now rather than you know having the
verifier just query it and decide
whether to accept or reject the verifier
tosses some coins
sends them over to the approver another
prover is allowed to send another pcp
string another long string
and you know they continue on like this
for a number of rounds
at the very end of the protocol the
verifier can decide you know a bunch of
points
in each one of these pcps or each one of
these long messages
read those and then decide whether to
accept or reject so of course
the one round version of this would be a
pcp and if you let
one query everything what you would get
is an interactive proof
okay so it seems like a somewhat strange
model and you might argue that it's
uh unnatural and you know i don't want
to go into that debate
what i do want to say is that you know
there's great motivation for this
because this model can be used as an
incredibly useful abstraction
at least in two ways that i know of so
first of all in this work with uh guy
and omar we used it to construct
something that's called a double
efficient interactive proof so proof
systems are statistical soundness in
which both
the prover and the verifier are
efficient and it's also
uh was used in this work of bensonsung
ksn spooner
to construct succinct arguments and
there's been a lot of work on that since
then
okay so there's a lot of motivation for
for this model
moreover it turns out that you can do
things in this model that we just don't
know how to do with pcps
in particular a work by benson song
gabisson reabsev
and spooner from a couple of years ago
actually showed that you can construct
iops with a constant number of queries
and linear communication for circuit set
okay so kind of the concentrate question
for iops
was already known and what we do in this
work is kind of improve on that
result in two ways which i will discuss
but one thing i want to point out is you
know
in terms of the actual communication in
this result that i'm mentioning
if we kind of borrow terminology from
error correcting codes and look at the
rate
of the iop which is basically just the
size of the circuit divided by the
communication
we would kind of the way that you would
get here is something that's pretty
close to zero uh
i think i checked in was 0.00
something maybe 0.005 i think
so kind of close to zero and our first
main result is constructing
an iop for circuit stat in which the
rate approaches one
so almost no overhead on top of the size
of the circuit
so more formally we show an iop with a
constant number of queries
and with communication arbitrarily close
to the circle side
okay a couple remarks about this theorem
so
around complexity is constant it's a
small constant but i think it's
a slightly larger constant than in the
previous work
independence sorry
independent independent of epstein fixed
constant
i think it's a single digit i don't
recall what it is exactly
um something like six-ish all right
anything that previous uh previous work
was
maybe four-ish no same ballpark
um so in terms of running time both
approver and verifier are quasi-linear
in the input which is a survey and we
can also achieve some
sub constant values of epsilon but then
your query complexity goes up
and also we can do this for you know
arbitrarily small epsilon but for some
sub constant values of epsilon and that
kind of gives you an iop with just
additive overhead
okay so questions about the first result
oops
okay so um so where is the cost
like what do you pay in when you get
when you plug in a very small epsilon
so it increases the query complexity um
i think at some point it will go into
the proof length but uh
i don't have it on top of my head
okay let's take it offline and i'll
double check
okay so uh that was the first main
result the second main result that i
want to tell you
for that i want a little bit of context
so let's look again at this
question about the length of pcps and
specifically
let's think of you know satisfiability
um
say uh cnf set where you have n
variables and m clauses
so the length of the empty witness is of
course just a satisfying assignment it
has length n
[Music]
but if you look at the length of the pcp
it's always kind of consistent
it's always proportional to the
non-deterministic verification time
of this language which in this case is
kind of linear in m
plus m so you'd get even the best pcps
that we have in the best iops
would have length m plus m and sometimes
n can be significantly smaller than m
and it's natural to ask you know
the unencoded proof is mbits what is the
you know
can you get something that is just
polynomial in n maybe even just linear
in m
and it turns out the question the answer
to this is no
at least under some complexity
assumptions standard complexity
assumptions
fourth nouns and phenomes show that you
know this is impossible
but luckily enough turns out that if you
look at iops
then a result by khalid roz stated on
somewhat different model but in modern
terms this is an iop
this would give you an iop with poly and
length something you just
cannot do with pcps
okay so you've got you know some so for
sat
klein was show uh iop with poly and
length
and our second main result improves on
that so
let's ignore for the second the first
sentence and focus on the second
sentence
what we give is an iop say for sat in
which the
the amount of communication is um you
know one plus epsilon
times the original witness times you
know m
[Music]
and the so that's the result the
sentence that i wanted you
uh need to ignore for for the moment
basically says that this is true not for
all
mp relations but rather all np relations
in which you can verify membership
verify correctness and bounded in some
fixed
bounded polynomial space
okay so for stat you can do this with
something like a logarithmic space
so some remarks about this result well
in terms of the richness the class that
we can capture
it captures a lot of interesting empty
problems in particular things like
i said stat and authenticity essentially
all 21 of carp's original
mp complete problems can can be framed
this way
um there's a small asterisk there but
let's ignore that
so that's one comment uh in terms of
communication
even ignoring the fact that the proof is
local just in terms of
the number of visa we're sending we are
uh
essentially optimal up to the additive
factors and this is assuming you know
the randomized strong exponential time
hypothesis
um let me not go into what that means
but it's uh
you know it's a complexity assumptions
that some people believe in and
will be amazing to refute lastly i
mentioned that the second main result
actually implies the first main result
because circuit satisfiability can be
verified it has an empty witness
which is just assignment to all the
gates or all the wires if you like
and that can be verified in you know a
very small space just go over everything
right and i'm going back to your
question about the format of the circuit
if you look at this result
what do you care about is just the it's
more about the length of the
witness and not about the actual
representation as long as it's something
you can verify in small space
okay so why can you verify this in small
space like the circuit the
satisfiability oh so if the witness is
the assignment to all the gates
okay so uh how am i doing on time
you know i haven't been measuring but i
guess we we
okay i'll just go out for the best i
think the slot was like 30 minutes right
so
uh i think the main concern is just to
leave some uh some uh
some break time uh in between talks but
beyond that
so let me tell you a little bit about
how we do this
and to kind of get started let's do a
very quick slide of background on error
correcting codes
so what is an error correcting code just
a function mapping you know
k bits to n bits it's an injective
function it's kind of
a length increasing or expanding
um right so on the left on the left left
ball is kind of a
set of messages they live in zero on to
the k on the right you have a set of
code words
that live in zero one to the m and we're
trying to have the coders be far from
one another
so if you get some corrupt codeword you
can put you can decode
[Music]
and the two main parameters that we're
going to care about
are the rate of the code just kind of
how much overhead you need to introduce
in order to do this
and basically just k over m
and the second thing is the distance of
the code or relative distance of the
code
which just measures you know the minimal
relative distance between any two code
words
minimum minimal relative hamming
distance
and in this talk all the codes that
we're going to talk about are linear
codes
which just means that they are linear
transformations say over gf2
okay so let's use codes to build pcps
and iops
and i'm going to focus first on the
problem of doing this for just
3sat you know as a very nice mp complete
problem
i'm going to show you in iop for 3sat
with squarewoodm query complexity
roughly
and later on we'll see how to extend
this to get you know instead of just
threesat
get this much richer class of all np
relations that can be verified
in bounded polynomial space and also
reduce the queer complexity to a
constant
but right now we have this goal of just
doing three sat and just
square root and query complexity
okay so how do people you know build
pcps
and i think that a good bird's eye view
of how it's done if you look at three
side is something as follows so
you know the input is a formula uh fee
on and
on bits and the witness is a satisfying
assignment for fiend
and you know the way usually pcps work
is something as far not always but
usually
it will be something that follows so the
prover sent over an error corrected
encoding
of x of the satisfying assignment
and this code c is chosen to be both
locally testable
and locally correctable i don't want to
define what these things mean but
what it essentially means is that the
prover kind of has to send over a valid
code word
it can do some corruption but they
somehow they won't matter so effectively
the approver has to send over a valid
code word
and lastly the code is designed to have
some
some sort of mechanism to check that the
message that is encoded within
satisfies the form of a fee
and notice that this check that we're
doing is a non-linear check
right that x satisfies the formula fees
to typically be a non-linear
test that you're trying to do and in
order to check non-linear relations
something that is usually used is
something that's called a multiplication
code
what's a multiplication code well
loosely speaking it's a code where if
you take
two code words and you take their point
wise product
what you get is still a codeword of some
maybe a related code
but it kind of it has distance okay so a
good example to have in mind is
something like read solomon code
in which the code words are just you
know truth tables of polynomials
and if you take two polynomials and take
their product together
what you get is another polynomial of
somewhat larger degree but it's still a
polynomial
still lives in a code still has distance
and the same
is true for things that read molar codes
or hg
direct geometry codes and
turns out that multiplication codes are
great because they're somehow they're
really the mechanism that lets us
check nonlinear relations and this was
beautifully articulated in work of
of ormeer from uh from 2013 a while ago
and we're going to be talking a lot
about his work it was very influential
for our work
um so that's the nice thing about
multiplication
codes the unfortunate thing about them
is that their rate is typically very bad
usually it's close to zero
and sub-constant usually and
in particular turns out that the rate is
inherently at most one-half
so there's a theorem showing that
multiplication codes always have rate at
most one half
and in our setting where we're aiming to
have rate close to one
we simply cannot uh we cannot
uh that's what we're looking for we
just cannot afford to send over cfx if c
is a multiplication code
so we're going to uh ignore that
momentarily and proceed on and try to
build pcps
okay so i'll do a quick crash course on
how pcps uh
kind of used to be built this is very
kind of 90s way of how pcps are built
uh so let's go on for for a couple of
slides of how pcp's used to be built and
let's see
how we're going to use that okay so
remember we have an input formula fee
we have a witness x which is a
satisfying assignment for fee
first thing that we're going to do is
kind of look at the satisfying
assignment as a truth table of a
function
so we have a function capital x mapping
log n bits to 0 1
with just you know this truth table is x
we're going to take the multilinear
extension of x so this is just
the unique individual degree 1
polynomial
that agrees with x on all boolean inputs
okay so that's our x hat and
you know for starters let's assume that
it's okay for the prover to just stand
over x hat
and you know in parenthesis i'll just
mention that this x hat as i defined it
has super polynomial length so we
definitely don't want to actually stand
over x hat
but for the moment let's imagine that
it's okay over x hat
okay so we have x hat in mind let's see
how we
kind of arithmetize well first thing
first thing that i want to do is define
another function it's called i sub phi
which basically represents
uh you know the the formula fee as a
function so
given indices i1 i2 and i3 of three
variables
and bits b1 b2 and b3 i sub phi on that
input
outputs one if our formula contains uh
the clause corresponding to you know x i
one equal to b
1 or x 2 equal to b 2 or x i 3 equal to
b 3.
okay so if you look at the function i
sub phi
directly corresponds to our formula
which closet it has
and which clause it doesn't have
and using i sub 3 i want to define
another polynomial
called p which has kind of the same
inputs
as i sub phi has but these inputs now
live in the field
and the way that p is defined is as
follows
so rather than uh okay so so let's start
this definition and see what it means so
if i plug in boolean values to p
then what do i get i plug in i1 i2 i3 b1
b2 and b3
if the the corresponding clause doesn't
appear at all
in feed then i'm going to get a zero
from the first term of this product
if the clause does appear then the way
i've set up the second part
the i will get a zero only if and only
if that clause is satisfied
right if there if for one of the js x
hat i j
minus bj is equal to zero
in other words our formula
phi is satisfied by x if and only if the
polynomial p
that i've just defined is identically
zero on all boolean inputs
and i want to point out that this
function fee that i've defined is indeed
a polynomial because
i took the low degree extension of i sub
phi that's a low degree polynomial
and i took its product with a bunch of
other polynomials and here's where
really i'm leveraging multiplication
codes i took
you know code words and i multiplied
them
okay so how do i check that my
polynomial p
vanishes on boolean inputs well the
short answer is to use sum check
the beautiful uh celebrated subject
protocol of landform carlophanissan
the longer answer is that you know
subject was designed to let you check
that
a sum over say the boolean hypercube is
equal to zero
but it turns out that there's a very
close variant that lets you check that
it's just identically zero on the
hypercube
so um that's basically how you know
some of the first pcps that we had were
built bf bfl and bfls
and something that i want to point out
is that in this entire construction
the verifier only needs to make a single
query to the polynomial p
and also we can use a constant round
version of the sum check protocol
to get a protocol with overall
communication
square root n okay so
if you lost me on this couple of slides
you know don't worry about it let's
see what we have so far we have an iop
in which the approver sends over x hat
which is really long
it's a problem we're going to solve it
the verifier checks that this x hat is
close to a multi-linear polynomial
the parties run the sum check protocol
on the polynomial p
and then the the single query that the
verifier wanted to make to the
polynomial p
can be emulated by making three queries
to the polynomial x hat
and this is simply because the way that
p was defined it just defined
was uh it only depended on i sub phi
and on three points of x hat
okay so this is how our iop looks so far
and as i mentioned the problem is that
we can't really afford for the prover to
send over x hat
and the key insight in in our work
is that rather than having the prover
send over x hat
we're going to have the approver send
over an encoding of x via some other
code
a high rate code so that later on using
additional interaction
you can emulate queries to x hat that
you want
using more interaction with approver
okay so this is kind of the key insight
and once you have that inside the paper
kind of writes itself
so so let's go through that but question
yeah is there a more generic version of
this some kind of a way of
maybe identifying a broader class of
applications in which the same kind of
idea can apply
kind of some kind of a hybrid pcp
or hybrid codes that you you want a code
you have an application that depends on
the code that has
extra properties and now you replace it
with the generic code and
absolutely so i certainly do view it as
an interactive reduction between codes
and it's interesting to kind of
formulate that
yeah i think one more data point of an
application could
be could justify this just doing it
without an extra application but
it does seem like a more general more
generally useful idea there's a
follow-up work of
uh um of budo kiesa and groth which
kind of takes a similar approach and
also uh relies on the simulation
i think they're the spirit is fairly
similar um it would be nice to find kind
of broader
broader things that you can do okay
um okay so what do we want
we want a code c that is one
uh high rate right it's rate is close to
one we want to be locally testable and
correctable so
just to ensure that approver has to send
over essentially a code word
and we want that you know as long as i
have oracle access to
this to cfx there's some way for me to
emulate queries to x-hat
using additional interaction with
approver so that's kind of what we're
looking for
and the way that we're going to do this
is using some something that's called
transfer codes
so what our tester codes are a beautiful
object that i really like
which work as follows so it's kind of a
way to
take a code and construct from it a new
code that has very useful properties
so take your favorite linear code c
mapping k bits to n bits
i'm going to define a new code c squared
whose input is now k squared bits and
its output is now n squared bits
and the mapping works as follows oops
so this is the way the mapping works
first so you take your message you view
it as a matrix and by a k by k matrix
first thing that you do is encode each
one of the rows using the code c
and then you encode each one of the
columns including the new columns that
you added
again using the code c
and if you're you know wondering why we
did it first rows and then columns turns
out that it doesn't matter
you can uh work that out so this turns
out to be a very useful way of
constructing codes
just to uh you know get a feel for the
for the code in terms of the rate of the
code it used to be
k over n now decay became k squared over
n squared
so the rate squared and it's also not
too hard to show that the distance also
squares
when using this transformation so these
are sensor codes
and we're going to use for our code c a
high rate tensor code so
for example what you can do is take your
favorite plain old high rate code scene
mapping say square root and bits to just
a little bit more than square root n
bits
so this is a high rate code and you can
construct such code with constant
relative distance
and now you look at c squared what do we
know about c squared well
for one thing it has high rate because
the rate just squares and
you know if you square something that's
close to one you get something that's
close to one
it turns out that it's locally testable
and there's an asterisk there so you
know there are some quirks about this
but i don't want to get into it
and you know this falls from a result of
vyderman basically
and turns out it's also satisfies local
correction which is something that we
need
and this is something that we showed in
a joint work together with tom gore and
govid romaniana yaran a couple of years
ago
and this is kind of a certain relaxation
of local correction that's good enough
for pc
for for our application
okay so you know we wanted the code c it
satisfies the first two bullets we're
just left with the left bullet we want
that given oracle access to cfx we have
an iot
for emulating queries to x-hat
so how do we do this and you know first
observation
is that because x-hat is a linear code
you can express
the evaluation of x hat at a point i as
just a linear combination
of the bits of x and that's what happens
for linear codes
and for a second let's kind of hide
these coefficients these are line
coefficients
and imagine that we're just looking at
the sum of the entries of x
right so we want to compute the sum of
the entries of x given oracle axis the c
of x
and the way that we're going to do this
is by using the subject protocol as
applied to tensor code
and again this comes from the beautiful
work of ormier
and the idea works as follows so this is
for those familiar with essentia code
it's
really just an abstraction of that for
general tensor codes
rather than just like multivariate
polynomials so we have our
input code word c and we're interested
to say in the sum of the blue part
some over the blue part so the way that
the protocol works is that
our prover is going to sum up all the
in this case the first three columns
okay which is what we're interested in
but it takes the sum you know the entire
thing both the blue and the orange
and sends over the sun to the verifier
that's this kind of call tilde
that we're sending first thing that the
verifier checks is that
call tilde is indeed a code word and
notice that if the approver is trying to
cheat and
you know trying to convince the verifier
that the sum is wrong it has to send
over an incorrect code word this call
could call tilde
will not be the actual uh sum of what's
going on
in c and we're going to catch that by
choosing a random coordinate i
i star and checking whether you know
the i start entry of what the prover
sent
is consistent with the codeword c that
we have in our hand
and we do this by just kind of reading
off the i start throw of c
and once we've done that you know we can
safely assume that call tilde
was computed correctly and the sum of
the entries
of its blue part will kind of give us
the result that we're looking for
so that is uh how we do
sum check for general tensor code
including for our high rate tensor code
but unfortunately you know this hiding
hand doesn't exist in reality we do have
coefficient
and doesn't seem as though at least i
don't know how to extend some check
to check general linear relations of you
know
general uh general coefficients
in classical pcbs this comes out but
this is kind of easy to resolve
by just taking you know the thing the um
coefficients that you care about
thinking of them somehow as a code word
and multiplying them multiplying c by
them point wise
that kind of plugs in the coefficients
and you can do some check on the
resulting you know
product code word but we don't have a
multiplication code
but nevertheless and this is again
following uh orr's work
it turns out that you can extend the
subject protocol
as long as your coefficient matrix has
rank one
and luckily enough it turns out that our
coefficient matrix
does have rank one this has to do has to
do with the fact that x hat
itself is a tensor code
okay that's basically it so just as a
digest of what was going on
what we did is used you know the
incredible unbelievable power of the
subject protocol
to switch between different tensor codes
as required so
we use the high rate tensor code you
know to actually encode the computation
but using subject we were able to switch
over as kind of also uval was hinting
at to different tensor code
which is a multiplication code and
that's the code that let us check
non-linear relations
okay so you already have a question
yeah so just if you try to use the
direct constructions of codes that have
right high rate and are
like multiplicity codes right that have
that are locally correctable and locally
testable assume
i mean maybe it's an overkill maybe it's
not enough but what is the
if they're high rate they won't so
you're asking about uh using the
positive codes for
as the high rate code or i see okay so
it's not
okay you said that you want a high rate
code that's the code you switch to right
it doesn't need to be multiple
multiplication code but it needs to have
high rate and be locally testable
and locally it doesn't need to be
anything there needs to be high rate and
then oh
all right right okay okay just by
transferring i got everything i want
right okay yeah so by tensoring you get
everything you want my question is if
you
if you use instead code maybe it's not
useful for you but
those kinds of explicit multiplicity
codes
have high rate and um they have
these very nice self-correction
properties and
you know it's basically these very
explicit codes that maybe can be viewed
as some fancy type of tensor codes
will it can it be useful so can you use
something better than
just uh directly one thing maybe to
point out about local correction
is you know people work really hard to
get locally decodable and locally
correctable codes
difficult area but in the context of
pcps
there's this notion of relaxed local
correction which basically means that
you know
if when trying to decode you encounter
any kind of corruption
you're allowed to just abort right
turns out that that makes life way way
way easier
so overkill to be aiming
i mean maybe you could use
multiplication codes and get even better
relaxed self-correction and so forth but
somehow you know strict self-correction
seems like an overkill for in this
application
okay for instance if you wanted to
reduce the round complexity of your iop
and still to the limit and still get
similar characteristics i assume that
the
fancier types of codes that maybe are
non-existent but fancier types of codes
would help you do it
so the question is is there some
obstruction of the fencer type of code
that would help you do it
and does it exist um
so what you would so like instead of
doing a single tensoring
uh do you know some higher degree
cleansering or something like that
the higher degree transferring actually
it's not good no higher degree tensoring
you will lose too much in the rate but
i'm saying that something that has the
same effect
without losing the rate and and for to
this end maybe some explicit algebraic
constructions
might help right i mean
in my mind and i think and it's it was
essentially proven in this follow-up
work by al that i'll mention later
that this general idea can be useful you
know
you can switch whatever code you want in
the first part it has
certain properties that you care about
say efficiency and then another code
which you don't need to actually
materialize in the second part so even
even including by read solomon in the
first part but packing together all the
symbols rather than
encode using each bit individually as
it's usually done
that already i think would buy you
something
okay definitely in terms of concrete
efficiency i think that would be useful
so maybe to to add to this
discussion the way that i personally
like to think about uh
this very nice idea is that you start
out with an iop
where your queries are in a richer set
rather than being point queries are like
some function
of the oracle okay in this case uh with
ron it would be like you know
multi uh multilinear queries uh
to uh the message right
and you know you go ahead and design
your iop in this
dream world that is not really real
right
and then you're left with this kind of
very let's say
specific task which is every query that
the approver
so claimed an answer for for this rich
query set now you have to implement
using normal point queries
and so now you have this sub problem of
coming up with
basically an iop of proximity for a
claim that says
this thing encoded according the way
that you want that the iop proximity
decides
this is the answer and this is the query
in this reach set
yes could run things like fry to check
to check uh right because then you're
quick and
it's plausible that you may have you
know some fancy codes where
maybe not by running some check but by
running some other
algebraic thing you might be able to
answer to implement using point queries
some other types of uh
richer query sets and maybe those which
are query sets you would facilitate
some other interesting properties which
could be maybe even just concrete
efficiency who knows great
i think it's very likely i think i mean
i i would guess
that there are interesting things to be
said there in that direction
and and how tight and back to one how
tight is the trade of fear between the
round complexity of the iot are you pin
the other parameters
what could you hope to get you need to
uh you know
everything that's hap essentially
happening is just some checks and we
really need a very low uh
we're not you know fiddling with the
number of rounds we need some check like
the three round version of sound checks
in
or two-round version of some check uh
how much further you can push it i would
i believe it can be improved for example
if instead of using
um this kind of bfls style pcp that
we're using internally if we use
something uh
kind of a short piece a shorter pcb
which has you know quasi-linear length i
think that would buy you
um an extra round that you can save
okay yeah
okay let me go back okay so far we just
talked about three stat and also query
complexity was square root n
so let me tell you about how we extend
the result turns out that that's
much easier than what we've done so far
so in terms of handling
working handling you know general
bounded polynomial space relations
then using uh this work together with
omar and guy
in that work we constructed a constant
round interactive proof for
um any bounded space relation or any
bounded space language
so things like computer polynomial time
and fixed bounded polynomial space
and in this result the verifier only
needs to make a single query
to the low degree extension of the input
so what we can do in terms of
constructing this our iop
is follow the same framework as before
the prover sends over a high rate
encoding of the witness
but now we're going to run the this rr
protocol
on the imaginary low degree extension of
the witness which no one
which you know the verifier doesn't have
but at the end of the protocol the
verifier you know spits out a claim
about the low degree extension at a
particular point
and now we can use you know this lin
check
this you know subject with linear with
tensor coefficients
to check that w hat of i is actually
equal to v
okay so it's kind of plug and play
instead of using vfls we switch to
this rr protocol so that's how we handle
bounded palm on the space to reduce the
queer complexity
down from square root and to a constant
we use a very uh
simple idea or a beautiful and complex
idea but
which right now i think people will
understand well called
proof composition so the idea would be
that instead of directly
querying the squared endpoints that you
want to uh
check something about you have the
prover sent over
a pcp string proving that if you had
read these points you would accept
or to be more accurate what you need is
something that's called the pcp of
proximity
and i don't want to kind of get into
what that means but you can more or less
think of it as a pcp in which you don't
you also make a few queries into the
input
and to actually make this all work you
it's technically a bit annoying you need
to make sure that
everything is robust meaning that you
know the square root end query
verifier not only would it reject with
high probability but rather
the what it would see the square root of
the things that i would see would be far
from anything that would make it accept
but again i don't want to get into the
details of that but i'm happy to
uh elaborate if people are interested
either uh
at the end of the talk or offline
okay so just to summarize our main
result was kind of this theorem two
which shows that any mp problem with uh
that can be verified
in bound polynomial space has an iop
with a constant number of rounds
constant query complexity and where the
entire communication
is just barely beyond sending you know
the unencoded witness
in terms of uh some open problems that
i'm interested in
well you know the most basic open
problem that's left is you know
get short pcps for circuit set now we
introduced more interaction can you do
it without
interaction let me point out that there
are two different directions you can
take this to one
is to improve the query complexity of
uh the result that i mentioned of
benzasson
and others but another is you know can
we construct
a high rate pcp with any non-trivial
query complexity
right so the known constant rate pcp
has pretty terrible it's constant rate
but the rate is pretty terrible it's
close to zero
can you do anything untrivial with very
close to one
that i find that really interesting and
one reason to hope is that turns out
that
in the closely related uh research area
of locally testable codes
something like this is known
so i'm really hoping someone comes up
with
such a result for pcps another you know
very tempting open question that i've
thought about
uh quite a bit and
have some initial thoughts but not not
anything uh too exciting is that
can you use iops to get better hardest
approximation results
okay because we do have these short iops
pcps are very fundamentally related to
hundreds of approximation can you use
iops as well
uh third question is you know are this
a result was limited to bounded
polynomial space relations
can we get rid of this limitation and
handle all of np with iops that
approach the witness length and
you know either a positive or negative
result would be cool here
i mean at first glance it's tempting to
think that you can show a negative
result but
at least to me it's not clear
lastly you know we said that one of the
main motivations for
short pcps is to improve the proof of
running time
and you know now that we have these
shorter iops can we also
improve the proof of running time and
turns out that the answer to this is yes
and this is a
follow-up work of budo kiesa and groth
which builds on our techniques and
constructs
iops in which the proverans in or
its sizes in arithmetic circuit is
linear
so it only needs to do a linear number
of arithmetic operations
over some sufficiently large field
okay and i'll uh stop here and oops
happy to take uh any additional
questions
thank you so much ron i did want to say
uh we're probably gonna start maybe
five minutes late in the next talk just
so that we have like a ten minute break
in between
and also i don't see much in a reason
for this ten minutes to switch over
together
down i think whoever wants to kind of
hang around here to ask questions or
just chit chat
uh maybe this is a good place to do that
to give in many ways the number of
people
but yeah go ahead then and if there are
any talks
questions
so question to ali the follow-up work is
the
something that appeared at tcc or i'm
not sure i mean
so this is the follow-up work that ron
is referring to the pc paper
yeah and you will hear more about it in
jonathan's talk i think on
wednesday okay great okay yeah yeah so
um
so one if i if i cared only about
epsilon equals one
meaning uh double doubling the
m yes so doubling the
the length and then the uh so at the
beginning you said that we have such
codes just that the rate is bounded like
by half
right that's it i mean that's an upper
bound the best multiplication because
that we have
i don't achieve this so the closest
thing would be a g codes
and that would essentially be uh if you
follow that route you would this is
essentially what this
prior work of l and others like at
constant rate
does i see
so it will give you a concentrate um
but the constant is somewhat limited for
arithmetic circuits you can get
you can use read solomon codes and get
the rate one half
essentially but it's slightly more
complicated right because you have to
consider
potentially either a tensor code or if
you are using the
the the multiplication property then
your rate is going to kind of go down
when you multiply two quadrants together
so you will find out after the
multiplication sorry
yeah i think you still need a little bit
of distance also after multiplication
yeah so i think you might go down to
like a fourth and an eighth uh it may be
an interesting question to see whether
you can sort of
start with the multiplication code and
end up with the rate uh
one half for the whole protocol
like i'm not sure how to carry it i mean
all the way
to the end of the product in the case it
also depends on how you uh arithmetize
because uh
i mean if you're depends on a little bit
of your uh
if you try to do pcp things rather than
iop things the arithmetization will also
introduce overhead
if you're already doing iop things then
why not kind of do this code switching
thing
yeah right this solution exists so you
need to have a good reason to
to somehow rule it out
maybe uh one thing that i wanted to say
and forgot is
um you know this work of or mayor i
already mentioned really influenced our
work and
something i find interesting is that
that work came out of like really pure
theory he was basically asking you know
can we build proof systems without using
algebra
and it was kind of okay you know he was
it was enough for him it was an actual
question it was kind of a
scientific curiosity i don't think he
anyone realized at the time that his
techniques would have
and i think it goes beyond our work i
think it's really influenced a lot of
recent works on iops
um but it once again shows that asking
you know basic
natural research questions leads to
interesting and unexpected results
i'm preaching to the choir but maybe
people are watching offline
what is your belief regarding three
sorry
what is your belief regarding question
three i started off i mean
saying you know obviously it's false but
then you know
i i'm no longer sure because um
you know you start off trying to throw
lower bands that you have for pcps
against this but they break down once
you switch to iops
and you try to uh throw doorbands you
have for interactive proofs on it but
they also break down um so like the
naive thing the immediate things that i
could think of in terms of lower bounds
didn't work
and in terms of upper bounds um
you know the main idea that i have is
using these double efficient interactive
proofs and they only work for
you know either bounded space or
boundary depth
and for that specific approach we don't
believe that we can generalize it
further right right
absolutely so we need so in upper bound
we need a fundamentally different
approach
and it seems and the lower bound as far
as i can see you would also need a
fundamentally different approach
it's this weird situation where i don't
know what the truth is
or don't have a good guess even and also
whatever techniques
one uses they have to be sensitive to
polynomial factors because we do have
iops where the proof length depends
polynomially on the witness length right
that is just the normal uh kind of ipc
no
but that is uh so that is either for if
you use it
like a lyra's use gkr that's for bound
to depth relations
well you can just do it for i mean the
dfls construction that then it would be
the circuit size not the witness not the
witness
length oh no you're right you're right
yes okay
okay so that maybe makes it uh more
easier too yeah so even even fixed
polynomial and the witness for
uh for empty yeah it's open as far as i
can see
yeah you're right
um okay so we're reaching uh
10 a.m california time uh different time
in different time zones
let's do maybe like a five minute uh
break before uh elon's uh i mean stick
around and do it
i'll do my break let's let's start
in five minutes with the next uh talk
thank you everybody and thank you so
much uh ron i think uh uh i'm very happy
we are recording because it was like
really
truly an excellent uh talk you know in
setting up stage
not just for your work but i think
it was it was a very good uh for
bringing people in from nearby areas
thank you clearly put a lot of work into
it appreciate it